all right YouTube welcome back to
another hangout super excited to be here
with my friend Stephen Kelly one of my
favorite CEOs in the world CEO of the
software company that I use to run all
of my accounting saij welcome back mr.
Stephen Kelly right away Evan I look
forward to these it's great to always
join with the big audience out there and
take their questions and we've got a
great topic this week so Stephens in
London I'm in Toronto today we're
talking about failure how to keep
failing and you will succeed and as
usual we're gonna kick it off before
getting to your questions with your
favorite segment quote time with Stephen
Kelly what do you got for us today
well exams the magic word says some
magic words from famous people anyone
that's never made a mistake has never
tried anything new the great Albert
Einstein inventor genius next one good
one a guy who's kind of big in social
media and big out there at the moment
really big with investors and looking
forward to the future great inventor
again failure is always an option if
things are not failing you're not
innovating enough Elon Musk nice and the
last one love this one too doing your
best at this moment puts you in the best
place for the next moment Oprah Winfrey
and then most of all the video Eddie
forever sub Kelly quotes fail fast
never fear failing learn quickly and the
last one an entrepreneurs life is one of
love and sacrifice but quicker you fail
the more you learn the more you grow I
love it I love it it's great buddy so
and for those of you hate I think those
are some great Instagram quotes that are
about to drop on Stephen Kelley's
channel go follow him there he's gotten
into the the stories now you can watch
him walk out of his house if you follow
him this morning I love it he's picking
up steam Yahiro on Instagram and so this
is great we have a bunch of questions
people are joining in already but but
before getting to that what is your
quick thoughts unfailing how at least a
success what how do you want kicks off
some advice yeah I think
the reality I'd probably still wear I've
been in entrepreneurship business
30-plus years and I fail every week
every month and I
you gotta learn from those failures and
then you have more experience you've
been on more journeys more adventures
and it dramatically improves your
chances of winning because that's the
price we're all after for you guys and
the other thing is I kind of think you
just never stopped learning that
curiosity desire and experimentation is
absolutely vital to think of the next
invention for your customers and build a
business around so I see kind of people
just freeze in the moment because they
fear failure and once with all these
things it's almost I guess when a bird
jumps out of the nest when they jump out
of the nest and they spread those wings
they can fly entrepreneurs you can fly
you just have to believe I like it I
like the end in there I just gotta
believe cool well let's get to some
questions we have 45 minutes together
first up is to lash to lash has been
hounding me to be on this livestream
he moved meetings around because he
wanted to make sure that we answered his
question so to lash we're kicking off
with you I'm worried that my business is
going to fail because in the planning
stages my co-founder is losing
enthusiasm due to advice from investors
in their own in their other businesses
how can I reinvigorate enthusiasm wow I
think that's great well tell ash I think
our there's a couple of things here I
think vibra brilliant startups and as
you grow to be a great company you've
got to create a culture of feedback and
also a big factor is that culture of
honesty I think you should kind of sit
down with your partner and say you know
is her head or his head in the game
because it sounds like it sounds like
from the description you provided
they're losing enthusiasm they're kind
of funders have got other other things
on and they're getting distracted what
it doesn't sound like is your business
idea is about business idea it sounds
like business idea is good but the
appetite the energy and the enthusiasm
and the passion has just diminished from
your partner so it's time to sit down
Coffee and say are we in this together
because this is a way we're gonna build
a field of dreams but we've got to give
it the best chance of being successful
and that's going to take passion energy
and sacrifice if he's not up for it or
she's not after it then you're going to
have the honest conversation then you've
got a sometimes say maybe it's not right
if you come back in a year 18 months
time but I'm gonna carry on with this
dream and I might need to get other
partners involved or other funders
involved friends and families to get off
the ground because because you know what
it is I think this is a factor you've
got to be super focused when you start
off and there's so much noise out there
that you can get distracted but you
gotta be super focused and that get that
relentless execution going and if
there's people on your team who's like
your partner you got worries about at
this stage you're much better off have
they honest conversation cut them free
and get back to what you do which is
grow your business yeah I'm with Stephen
on this one I think if your business
partner is already losing steam and
you're only in the planning stages it's
gonna get a lot rougher and so they need
to be a hundred thousand percent onboard
with what you're doing and with the
mission and they can be so easily swayed
by somebody else's voice
then then I'm with Steve and I think you
need to have that honest conversation
and if that means it needs to totally
break from the company or they I like
seems idea like maybe they have to come
back in six months 12 months 18 months
at a lower percentage it's a tough spot
to be but this is a marriage and you
don't want to get in get into business
with somebody who's doesn't have the
passion because you want to build
something really special and if they're
their interest is gone right now we're
losing right now because of what one
person would say about it that's uh
that's not giving me a lot of great
vibes for working with this person long
term now actually very practically to
lash what you could do is if they say I
just haven't got the time or commitment
or I'm doing other things well take
their money say we'll give you a lower
cut of the company because you're not
all working in it but just give them a
small small percentage take the money
use it to fund the growth and say you
know let's let's meet back in whenever
six once a year's time and you might
have more time on your hands but it will
obviously be diluted by that time you'll
take
gave him smaller percentage he's right
Maxine Steven gotcha Thanks
I guess this is the heart decision good
luck to lash one of many hard decisions
to come as being a leader that's what
leadership is all about making those
tough calls
so tell ash it sounds like you know what
by saying it's a hard decision it's an
easy decision you made the choice every
decision you take as a business you're
an entrepreneur tillich you can say as a
hard decision I promise you it's just
another decision whether it's hard or
easy is just a voice in your head it's
just a decision it's literally five
minutes coffee take him down coffee shop
not gonna work does he want to put his
money man if he does then you know it's
a smaller percentage but it allows you
to be really clear also what it allows
you to do is get double down on your
vision don't be distracted you know when
you're when you're fighting a war you've
got to have everybody on your shoulder
you can't you can't have any there's no
room for deserters
yeah multiple Instagram quotes right
there from Steve and Kelly I love
whether it's harder it's easy it's just
a voice in your head that's great I like
that I might I might use that myself
that's great all right let's move on
Salima saying how do you make sure your
failures don't cost you a lot of money
I think isalean that's a great question
what I say is from from the get-go you
want to have a culture of feedback and a
culture of experimentation and I would
always try and kind of isolate and
there's loads of different ways of doing
this in terms of sampling so if you've
got a product idea test it out of a
focus group test it with friends and
family refine it improve it take the
feedback and then you know there's
always way kind of the golden rule
around this is you don't want to do kind
of big bang bet the house on it what you
want to do is kind of do bite-sized
chunks of execution you want to break
the elephant down cut the elephant up
break it into small chunks and you know
if you wasted you know $500 or on a good
idea but that gave you the input and the
feedback where you could make it a
winning idea that's probably the best
business decision you made and then with
all these things the best way to execute
is take that first step
and do it so button best advice I can
give you is cut the elephant down I
think they say in Canada getting a moose
on the table let's put the moose on the
table and let's kind of skin it and cut
it up and just take bite-sized chunks
you can always break any business
problem down or any product launch and
you go to market any website anything
down into small bite-sized chunks
don't try and boil the ocean never boil
the ocean yeah I agree I think it's easy
to have a big vision as an entrepreneur
you can see where it's gonna go and to
make that big vision happen now you need
venture capital now you need a huge team
now you need all these resources and
that's exciting but it's also scary and
it gets scary to the point where it
comes as such a big idea that you can't
you become paralyzed and you don't do
anything so the big vision is great and
then go down to what's the easiest
dumbest simplest way to do something
just start taking action in the smallest
possible way today
sampling whatever it is you know you
want to start a YouTube channel just
take out your phone and start filming
don't worry about the gear and the
equipment and the editor and all that
stuff just start find the smallest
possible way to start and have the big
vision I think I think people too often
play in the middle and them end up just
being paralyzed by fear Mitchell is
commenting on your leadership thoughts
there Stephen Stephen what
differentiates someone from a great
worker to a great leader
that's a great question mature and I
think it's kind of a great leader
actually recruits great followers and
they could be followers on social media
you go where the audiences could be
great customers could be great partners
could be great employees and I think
it's sort of what Evan said you've got
to have a great vision if you can have a
sense of purpose how you're going to
change the world with your product or
service and what it means and it's
compelling they're new you and 90% there
and then you've got to be able to
communicate that vision and then people
will get excited and that's half the job
of leadership then obviously the other
part is you've got a you got to build an
execution plan you've got to build a
plan and all the things we talked about
before start small with a big dream to
go big but all
to mately you will find people very
excited and you kind of want to put kind
of checkpoints in three months time
would have done this sort of volume
these subscriptions new customers
whatever the metrics are and then it's a
really powerful and compelling cocktail
when you come back in you recruit the
first few people that you got to buy
your vision to say guys we did it
celebrate success down the pub down down
on a Friday night and applaud your
fiftieth customer although it's really
important in a little stage company
because you run that thousand miles now
to celebrate the successes and celebrate
the wins and it could be a product
launch could be your 50th customer it
could be whatever it could be the first
you know hundred thousand dollars of
revenue but when you get that it's great
to kind of take everybody down and just
because you want to create mythology you
want to create and savor the moment you
know you run a you'll probably work 70
hours a week because you do it your love
but my advice would be both from the
failures and the successes save at the
moment kind of do the retrospective what
do we learn if it's a success then if it
is something where you really want to
just get people to pause reflect
meditate and say wow we did it we did
what people we define the cynics we
achieved what none of us thought was
possible and we're on the path to
achieve our dreams Stephen Kelly is on
point today you want to create mythology
I love it you're some magic cuff links
this morning or something happen you
like you like imagine Evan I love it you
want to create mythology that's a leader
speaking right there my two cents to add
to this would just be you have to start
caring about others more than yourself
if you're a hard worker you care about
your output your productivity what
you're doing you may be the highest
performer in the company it's great but
when you are a leader you have to
recognize that you're still gonna work
hard but the people around you end up
contributing more to the company than
you do right you know Stevens got 12,000
15,000 how many thousand employees now
net he might be the single most
important person in the company but net
they contributed way more than he does
and so the greatest leverage he can
bring is to help them grow as people and
bring more productivity
to the team so when you shift
perspective I am going to be the person
doing the output - I need to empower my
team to be more productive and grow as
people that's what I think makes a great
leader hey the other thing I have a
little quote here you know great leaders
when things are going well push their
team to the front and celebrate their
team and put them on the podium for the
Oscars when things are going bad and
there's crisis then great leaders take
the role at the front and provide the
leadership and direction that everybody
needs to galvanize around I like it I'm
still stuck on you you want to create
mythology that was great I'm pacing out
on my wall thank you for the insights
from a great leader so awesome awesome
awesome ok lots of questions coming in
let's see what should you teach what
should you teach kids about failure when
school punishes them for failure that's
a great question
you know that is such a great question
what you want to do it's kind of what
would I do you know I'm a parent I've
got three amazing daughters and I just
love to see them experiment but when
when you see either in American schools
Canadian schools British schools
whatever this whole culture of like tick
boxes and this culture where it's not
about experimentation it's really how do
you learn you learn through failure you
learn through successes you learn more
from failures than you do successes and
also where you have a really strong
culture of feedback like ask yourself
those great open questions like what
went well what we could we're done
better what would have been even better
if all those questions always mean that
you better get better quality outputs
net time in less time so how do you do
it aren't at the start of the year I
probably as a parent go into the school
and sit down with the teacher and say
you know you're obviously huge
experienced teacher really looking
forward to this year but I've tried to
encourage my children to experiment and
try things and obviously they'll be well
behaved and all those sort of table
stakes but we really want to bring our
kids up with an ethos where ultimately
they fear no failure and obviously they
to success but when when failure happens
as it does worse in exams or tests or on
the on the soccer pitch or the baseball
ground you know they learn from that and
and therefore it's a very encouraging
environment and it's not a kind of
caustic hostile environment and if you
kind of put that out there it's pretty
hard for a teacher to say well kind of I
don't agree with that so I think with
all these things from the get-go is
probably worth being honest and
authentic and obviously you always
support the teacher of the school you
send them to but the other thing I'd do
I'll be honest is my experience this is
a totally different question what would
I say about my kids Evans got kids as
well I can't believe how different my
kids are three kids they're totally
different personalities and I've found
out through you know just reality of
where they are they need different
things from schools I would go into a
school and I'd put them into school with
massively strong sort of pastoral care
support and a great culture I'd pick a
school with a great culture and part of
the culture is from the head or the kind
of key key leader in that school and the
tone that they set at the top in terms
of a culture of experimentation learning
not just learning to kind of tick boxes
and pass exams but learn about
relationships learn about communication
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
music drama sport learn about the
richness that kids should really relish
and enjoy through life they're all the
main come amazing leaders entrepreneurs
of the future and great citizens so I
kind of would my advice would be pick a
school which is aligned with your
culture and the culture here is
obviously a culture of success but a
culture of feedback a culture where
there is no fear of failure but failure
is just part of life for me it's a great
learning opportunity and you'll you'll
very quickly when you go and listen to
the top guys in these schools and the
top ladies in this course you'll get a
very clear view of what the culture is
so I'd pick it on culture first and if
you can't do it then go along from the
get-go with a teach at the start of the
year and say you know these are kind of
the way we want to support our kids how
to have
work with your environment because
you're the boss in the classroom and we
want to support you but we just want to
make sure our kids grow learn and love
their year with you I love it we've got
a student watching her saying I'm at
school right now waiting for the bell to
ring and I'm watching this you know what
I agree with Stephen what I would add is
I think you you still need to take the
responsibility to teach your kids the
values that you feel are important to
instill I think too often parents just
assume that the school will take care of
everything where is this still your role
your job I think the best thing you can
do is provide a shield for your kids I
remember when I was in school I got a I
failed in our class because my teacher
asked me to draw a sunset and I drew a
bedroom window with with drapes and as
in a sunset in the background with a
beach and abode and and my parents said
what's the problem and she drew a sunset
where all the other kids just drew a
sunset I drew the room in a sense it was
in the background and so our parents
kind of stood up for me to say hey he
still you weren't specific you still do
the sunset he just added some more
flavor to it and that nurtured my
creativity instead of squashing it and
so I think being a shield for your kids
and not just in school just for
everything for their kids for their
sports teams for everything they get
involved in giving them air cover being
that shield for them one of the things
that that Hayden and I always do is we
embrace weirdness so if anybody says
that he's weird or something's weird so
that's great it's great to be weird who
wants to be the same as everybody else
and so I think instilling that from an
early age is really important and you
taking the personal responsibility to do
that as a parent curious Akif is writing
in evidence Steven how do we bounce back
from a failure that's great and I think
key feeling bottom line is you need to
sort of create and this is a tough one
to do I recognize that because you're
running a hundred miles a day every day
as an entrepreneur is a roller coaster
ride it's all kind of white-knuckle ride
of ups and downs but you've got to go
into it with a mindset of what a success
look like define there and it's not
binary it's not black and white as it is
kind of many shades of kind of gray in
terms of what
this looks like what hitting the ball
out of the park looks like and therefore
the consequence of what failure is is
pretty stark if you run out of money or
something like that but in the context
of the critical thing I think we should
do and looking back at me I could do
this more is kind of what what's the
word have a kind of retrospective so
when you try to do something you you
have that time with you and the guys
you've hired maybe even your customers
like what could have been better what
could we have done better together how
what do we learn from this how are we
gonna learn from this so next time we
absolutely smash the ball out the part
that culture of feedback is very very
powerful if you do that the reason why
I'm saying this is it takes all the
emotional way because then it's just a
very rational objective discussion like
this was the outcome it was a product
launch or a new product to market or a
campaign we ran on social media and it
kind of didn't work out the way we
expected it to well let's look at what
happened what we've done better what if
and then what could we try next time and
you very quickly does two things for you
one is it takes all the emotion away
because you know the end of the day
obviously you're passionate about what
you do in your dream and emotional and
you get that but the worst thing you do
is feel crushed and have all the energy
suck tell you because then it takes I've
been in a boxing ring with you know some
incredible box it takes your time to get
off the canvas and get yourself up and
dust yourself down again
and you want to minimize that and then
the other thing is it kind of the
learning experiences what could we do
different next time what are we what
would have been a realistic outcome and
what will we have done differently for
the next time that we learn from so we
become better entrepreneurs better
leaders every day I love it I would add
I think you need to change the mindset
around failure I think if you looked at
any of the people Stephen quote at the
beginning Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey they
failed so many times the topic of this
is keep feeling you will succeed the
most successful people have failed more
than most people even try and so the
more you surround yourself with those
stories whoever does you look up to an
athlete a musician an entrepreneur or a
CEO like whoever that person is find
their story surround yourself with it
because they fail
so many times again they failed more
than most people ever even try and so
that's just part of the process so you
don't need to bounce back for it because
you expect it it's not it's not a
personal attachment like just because
you failed in one idea doesn't mean that
you are a failure as a human being and
separating those two allows you to move
forward without having to take a huge
personal hit so I think just surrounding
yourself with with that mindset of
people who have failed over and over and
over again and eventually win can shift
your mind around it to help you move
forward and stay positive Talaash is
asking a follow-up question he was our
first question of the day yes LS
evidenced even keeping memories or
reminders of past failures forefront for
encouragement versus putting those
difficult memories away and focusing on
endeavor and in hand thoughts on I don't
know what that means what's what's
what's both of your balance okay so
those failures you do you keep them
front of mine for encouragement or lock
them away and move forward what are your
thoughts yeah I think there's it's also
kind of where you get your energy from
everything this is pretty important if
you kind of do what we set around the
culture of feedback and I think you're
right so the last question is if you
actually want to say it's okay to fail
and you know then really smart people
fail fast and learn quickly you don't
want to perpetrate your failures and
kind of do it year after year but on
this one
you know once you've failed you're the
same entrepreneur you were before the
failure so what you don't want to do is
is deplete your energy you still want to
have that passion the energy but now
you've got some additional learning so
you're a greater leader and a better
entrepreneur you've got more experience
the reason why I say this is I've seen
this sometimes is sometimes after a
failure people just freeze they lose
their confidence whereas it's a time we
should rationally you should be bolder
because you've got more experience so if
you objectively look at it you know I've
learned we've done these two projects
these experimentations neither worked
but I learned XYZ from these and be very
specific
about what you learnt so that next time
I do this I'll know what kind of great
looks like I know great outcomes I know
how to do it I know about the execution
then just back yourself you know you've
got to believe in yourself and back
yourself what you never want to do is be
in the moment and listen to those voices
in your head saying you can't do this
you know you did this last time you
found last time you've got to shut that
away and and there's lots of different
ways you could meditate whatever you
want to do just to get yourself grounded
in the moment connect if you've ever
struggle and we all have days where you
know Evans probably had days where
sometimes you doubt yourself and you
feel vulnerable I think that's a great
element of leadership great leaders I've
always seen in the past have
vulnerability that they're happy to
share but then you've got energy around
you with your friends your family your
partner's be customers where they lift
you up and say let's reconnect ourselves
to the vision the ambition the dream
what we're trying to do at the sense of
purpose and then put in the context of
learnings from the failures but against
the mission for success and really make
sure you be bold and just crack on and
do it yeah I agree I think you have to
play to your personality I think you
want to make sure that whatever pain
you're inflicting on yourself is a kick
forward not down if you're just reliving
all these really painful moments and you
feel depressed and terrible about
yourself that's not going to serve you
to do something amazing but if it
motivates and inspires you to move
forward then then use it I think every
superhero has a dark side I think the
dark side that the pain that you have
can help fuel you to move forward but I
think if you live too much in that pain
it'll be toxic to you and negative so
you're you know 95% optimistic and
positive and 5% be fueled by the pain I
don't look backwards at all I don't I
don't really remember what happened in
the past and what's happened I use I use
the pain as forward-looking so that
whatever I might be afraid of whatever
failure might be afraid of right now I
just imagined the next 70 years of not
having taken action on that and the
future regret dying then I'm gonna feel
and bring that back to today and how
huge that weight feels on me but then I
have to go and do the thing that I'm
scared of so that's how I'll use it
that's my dark side 5%
I don't really look backwards I guess as
long as it's serving you and it's a kick
forward not down then play to your
personality similar what Stephen said
just may be different words yeah I think
Evan the other thing is and this is
where you see great leaders the great
leaders have a fantastic internal Karma
where they get inspired because of their
dream but it's very much an internal
kind of drive that inspires people
around them as well but we all know
let's just be honest we probably all
know people are very fatalistic and
always take external sort of elements
and kind of blame stuff and they say
well because this happened because Trump
get elected for this or the economy
turned down or whatever and then it's
all these external things where you
become a victim and all the great news
I've met all the great business people
you know they just kind of they just
roll with the punches they learn they
listen they take feedback and then
literally they reinvent themselves and
they sometimes change your behaviors not
only change to strand a bit of course
correction here on the execution what
they also tend to do you know slight lie
Kevin I never I never live in the past
but I learned from every moment at the
past and try and apply that to the
present in the future and build the
future because of that is you kind of
write the write the learnings down in
terms of playbooks kind of bottle it and
blueprints and cranny if you know like
ever before we learn this we're talking
about just the Instagram he said can I
hold my little camera this way not
landscape I've learned you know it's
just bounce back that's a great bit of
learning great bit of culture of
feedback and and as a leader you want to
have antenna I out there all the times
on your customers your partner's social
media to just take constant feedback and
do course correction but ultimately the
most important thing is your belief your
dream your passion your drive and that
internal energy that inspires you but it
will inspire other people and never feel
a victim yeah I think winning all the
time
sucks to like the drive the push the
losing helps you be more competitive if
you were constantly doing spelling tests
against three-year-olds you'd win every
time but that's not fun you get super
bored of that
the challenge the learning helps you
grow to be better and I think the best
entrepreneurs embrace that challenge
they loved the failure as much as they
loved the wayans to get better and win
there's a lot of people riding in with
various forms of judgment so they're
afraid of failing in front of somebody
else they're afraid of what other people
will think of them where they fail like
multiple versions of that question what
advice you have to eliminate the fear of
judgment for your failure for in front
of other people I think um I think your
on the previous one I should have known
since I was a little I'm a little bit
dyslexic sauce I wouldn't be
guaranteeing my spelling competition
that's cool no judgment judgment oh man
this is such a critical word isn't it
I'll say you know you want an
environment especially your friends your
family and it's the same there you you
are and you cast a big shadow but what
is judgment and it's so easy to have
these voice in your head how many times
have we had voice that said about
someone feeling about something towards
us where they think we've really screwed
up and then a year later you sit down
you have a beer with them and they
didn't think that at all so I kind of
think all you can be responsible forever
is yourself you can't be responsible for
how other people feel or what
conclusions they draw or what judgments
they make but I think what you can do in
terms of be very clear and say look
before you go off on your journey you're
gonna do it experiment your product say
look there's always risk that's why
we're here that's what we love and this
is what success looks like but what
we're going to do is experiment we're
going to kind of do a couple of
prototypes samples whatever and we're
going to learn from that so then it
becomes just very objective very
dispassionate very unemotional and
actually it means that there's very
little judgment the only judgement is
how do we improve how do we learn for
next time how do we win next time
and and then you know I think people can
really struggle in that environment even
if they're the most critical people and
they may even sort of SAP and suck
energy from you and oxygen it's tough to
argue with that so odd I'd say you know
if back to our Evans whole ethos is
belief back yourself really take
responsibility for yourself because at
the end there you can't take
responsibility for other people how they
feel or what judgments they make but you
can take responsibility of how you
interact with them and how you kind of
set up for success and also just
acknowledge right from the get-go so one
of the possible outcomes is yet you
might fail on this project but you'll
learn a hell of a lot and you'll bounce
back and be stronger yeah I agree I
don't think people actually that afraid
of failure I think they're afraid of
failure in front of somebody else and
that's what prevents people from taking
action I think one starting from a place
of empathy understanding and these
people probably love you if your parents
are hating on your idea to be an
entrepreneur because they want you to be
a banker they just want you to be
successful and so if you understand that
they just see success differently from
you do it can take the sting out of the
words as opposed to fighting with them
because it's coming from a place of love
most of the time to just understanding
that you don't want the same things that
they do like these friends of yours
these people around you they want a
different life and so you should not be
taking advice from the people who are
doing different things from you and
three for the motivation encouragement
again I would just surround myself with
content resources books podcasts videos
of people who have been leaders and have
taken the role and have fought against
everybody who's hated on them back to
Stevens quotes at the beginning Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and all these
leaders if you want to be an
entrepreneur you're doing something
different and by that very definition
you're gonna have people who don't like
the difference they like the status quo
that'll be most people so you're gonna
get a lot of people who are say that
your ideas won't work and then fighting
against you that's okay that's part of
the process and the more you surround
yourself with with those people
Elon must of the world watching the
videos and the BIOS and all that
hopefully some of it seeps into you to
negate some of that negativity but at
the end of the day you don't want the
same things they do so at what point are
you gonna live your version of your life
instead of your friends version of your
life Livio version of your life yes
create
I love it create love Stephen Kelly
you're a legend okay what else
Loreena is asking what is your
definition of failure that's a great
question Arina you hit the nail on the
head cuz your definition will be
different from the next person's
definition be different from your
partner's definition and also I sorry I
heard this from someone I've never heard
it before in terms of who you are and
what sort of things you look for and
it's kind of the vowels AE I owe you and
I'll come back to the first one the
first one's kind of attitude and
ambition because if you got that you got
everything and then kind of excellence
II and then I'll come back to the others
but hey let's start with ambition so I
think Larina
I think entrepreneurs are hugely
inspiring and you need nearly always
have sort of daesh's ambitions in terms
of what you want to achieve and your
dreams and I think also as part of that
it's really important you kind of set
realistic goals in terms of outcomes
always always start with the end in mind
so you don't start from today and how
you look forward you start you know
dreaming really what would we like to be
you know Evan what how would it feel
Evan if today in two years time we're
sitting here in two years time it's what
2020 and you've got a million Instagram
followers and we've got live not only in
Canada u.s. everybody you're an
entrepreneur you you know you're on the
Kramer show tonight you know this is
this is real time this is so you think
about that now if that's the case what
do I need to do to get there what are
the steps I need to do this month either
Evans problem you know he's aware of
12,000 followers now so it kind of by
the end of a month is it 20,000 so you
kind of work and if I'm going to do that
who do I need to have in terms on the
show what do I need to do how do I
change the social media presence how do
I do more interactive stuff how do I
start doing podcast all these sort of
things so there's a whole load of things
you can do once Larina you have a view
of what the outcome is
what a success look like because that
defines everything and then that also
allows you to say actually reality is
failure is just not a once-in-a-lifetime
moment failure is a whole series of
steps that you learn from and and then
you it gives you real context to say
right if that's what I want to achieve
yeah two years what I need to achieve
this month is this what do I need to
achieve this week is this and then you
can sit down Friday afternoon with your
buddies your partners and say why how
did we do you know did we did we set out
and did we achieve what we wanted to and
then you can have a very honest
conversation well if we didn't you know
what could we have done differently what
could we've done better what could we
have done you know and what did we do
celebrate what if we do well what went
well this week and what do we need to do
and all with these things obviously you
want to build that muscle memory of
doing more of the stuff that works and
obviously kind of stopping the stuff
that doesn't work so the critical thing
about failure is fail fast and set
everything up for success but fail fast
like like rapid speed lightning speed
and shut stuff down that's not working
and then put the energy in the muscle
memory into what is working so I kind of
think Larina the the reality is number
one your definition of failure will be
different from everybody else's because
it's pretty subjective the way you
galvanize people around your definition
of success is number one obviously focus
on success don't worry about the Phegley
because if it happens it happens but you
sure there's a leader focus on success
walk that's great like what does success
look like define that so then with your
partner you can say you know it's X
number of customers number of followers
number of leads whatever it is number of
product launches and then you say well
how do we achieve that and get everybody
really focused on the execution plan to
make that happen and then obviously say
right we're gonna do a weekly iteration
weekly retrospective we're gonna check
in where we are against the plan and we
will course correct it you know that's
reality of great companies great teams
they never stay still they're always
innovating they're always changed and
they're always challenging themselves
and if you do that you'll have a great
culture in the company you built
I love it my definition of failure would
probably be allowing the failure to
define you I think if we just reframe
the conversation on failure is it's just
feedback it's just a way to not do
something again the next time but the
only failure is if you decide to stay
down and not do anything about it
that's failure you have a dream you want
to do something you tried once didn't
work and so now you're gonna live
somebody else's life for the rest of
your life instead of trying again so if
you learn from it it's not failure if
you allow that field to define you then
that's failure in my opinion Sherry's
saying I'm so scared I'm scared to death
to change my business because I don't
want to either fail or hurt some
feelings what advice do you have hey
sherry I I think as a leader people will
look to you to be bold and therefore the
thing I think is really important it's
almost like that previous conversation
there are no hard conversations if you
have a relationship with people to work
for you your customers as well where
it's authentic and it's honest and you
always say look I'm gonna bring there
the Moose in the room and we're going to
talk about this we've got to find a way
forward people people you know that
emotion of hurting people goes away
because and if the person struggles with
that and they get emotional it just
maybe yeah take a bit of time out let
the emotions dissipate there's loads of
time so I'm sure Evans you know in a
moment you flash of either passion or
anger you know half an hour later a day
later you've forgotten all about that so
in the moment just let it go but then
come back and the way to really
reconnect people is this is what we want
to aspire to achieve together reconnect
them to the dream the sense of purpose
so how do we how do we actually get
ourselves organized to do this you know
what's working between us maybe we need
to change that and and like again what
Evan said is golden feedback is the
breakfast of champions
if you have that f-word popper
in your head around failure switch it to
feedback switch of the feedback and
change it in the moment to feedback and
then you know with with the person
you're thinking you might hurt their
feelings I guarantee if you're honest
with them authentic and you actually put
it in the context of what you in your
company is trying to achieve you you
will gravitate them really quickly to be
an objective dispassionate unemotional
and very often when when I've had these
conversations people come back either a
week later or even years later and say
I'm really glad you had that
conversation with me at the time
probably yeah it was a tough
conversation me but I I really
appreciate your honesty and I learned
from that moment actually was a couple
of people that said it changed the
course of my life for the good feedback
is the breakfast of champions Steven
Keller he's drinking some special water
today that's great I love it I want to I
want to rewind to the beginning again to
your to your whether it's a hard
decision or an easy one it's just your
mind says it was the way you said it was
great I go back and write it down it's
my fault feedback is a breakfast of
champions and you want to create
mythology this is gold sharing what I
would say is the the reason to quit a
business is because you've lost your
passion for it and you can't let past
success now be the anchor to your future
success because now you've lost the
excitement for what you're doing and the
way they don't get through this if
you're scared to death to change your
business I would do what I talked about
in the last answer I would just project
another 50 years of doing this and how
painful that's gonna be doing this thing
that now you hate doing and you're just
gonna hate it more and more and more and
more and more and just gonna disappoint
more and more and more and more people
as you keep building this thing up and I
just mount so much pressure myself but
then it becomes easy to make the
decision to then switch right I think
intention matters I think if some
people's feelings may be hurt having the
honest conversation we talked about that
in the first in the first question that
Steven brought up just have the honest
conversation if they know that you're
not trying to hurt them which you aren't
then hopefully they can understand the
switching direction but you don't want
another 50 years of this and so make
that decision now instead of wait
another 3 6 12 18 months
we got time for one more a trip okay
the pion is asking evidence Steven
what's the most unexpected thing you
have faced as an entrepreneur and how
did you tackle such a sudden change
probably for me it was when I was was a
Nasdaq CEO in California and we had
something called the dot-com crash boom
the Nasdaq market went from 5,000 to 800
in a matter of weeks
and when I was kind of driving down just
up to San Francisco in the city
literally I think there was about a
million jobs displaced in nine months or
something crazy unemployment in the bay
went from either three percent to 12
percent in a year and and we drove down
the 101 and either side you just had
see-through offices Wow when you have
that sort of shock treatment you have to
adjust at the speed of light and
actually we haven't said this but oh my
god that was a really hard time we had
to double down it was adversity every
day it was like it was a lot almost like
a time where all the assumptions you've
made kind of went out the window and all
the elements where you sort of built a
secure business plan and you know
everything changed now why am I telling
that because point number one is when I
look back and reflect on that period of
my life I learn more than I ever did in
any other period you know when I've had
successes I've never learned as much as
that period of life where we you know
went from flying with Eagles to kind of
been ground smashed and pulverized where
we had to bounce back but again the
great leaders learn DoubleDown sort of
took the cost base down to make sure
their company survived as I did and we
did as a team effort you know there's no
I in team
team stood up team were immense and then
I think all of us learnt so much in
terms of the experiences we gained you
know it's easier to be a team when
you're winning every day but the great
teams really overcome that adversity and
become sustainably great for the
long-term so so that was the the big
shockwave in terms of
my life it was dot-com crash I love it
um I have a hard time with these kinds
of questions because I spend zero time
looking back so if I had to pick
something probably my early days as an
entrepreneur my first business feeling
like a total failure I thought it'd be
easier than it was and shame to my part
that I quit and then just realizing that
this was too important that I wanted to
see it through that I could deal with
the failure but not dealing with not
knowing and that's a lesson that served
me still today but yeah I don't know I
don't spin we've talked about it before
I don't really spend a ton of time
looking back and so much rather how do
we how do we build something great going
forward but thank you for the question
Stephen we're bumping up against the
clock how do you wanna how do you want
to wrap this up give us a nice gift
yeah little gems today so it's gonna be
hard to top that oh go deliver I always
love these I hope the guys out there
enjoy it in terms of and get some great
content and to food in terms of their
business adventures and dreams there's a
great quote from a guy called Winston
Churchill in the last century success is
not final failure is not fatal it is the
courage to continue that counts and I
just think there's so many Islanders we
can take from the sporting field into
business dealing with failure overcoming
it it really marks the essence of a
great leader and I think you know in
terms of really practical advice replace
that f-word with feedback create a
culture where you have a culture of
vibrant feedback in the moment and it's
a learning culture where you absolutely
have a dream a passion a sense of
purpose and a an environment that you
create within your companies that you
start where people really know they're
connected with your vision to be
successful but it's a culture where they
love coming to work and they're learning
every day because they're getting
feedback there really matters I love it
well Stephen thank you so much for
spending your time with us today
thank you everybody watching I'm sorry
we couldn't get to other questions but
join in early next time so you can get
your question asked thank you guys again
for watching continue to
leave and we'll see you soon thanks Evan